durante los últimos tres meses alicia ha
estado cuidando mucho a un pequeño
huésped
[Música]
esta cría de oso hormiguero huérfana
pesaba 2 kilos 200 tendría que haber
tenido por lo menos 6 kilos estaba
completamente pelado por el estrés por
la mala nutrición
así que ahora está súper bien
cuando pase de los 20 kilos el animal
podrá ser liberado como la mayoría de
sus congéneres que se recuperan en este
centro el 80% de los osos hormigueros
aquí atendidos son reintroducidos con
éxito en la naturaleza a partir de los
10 meses ellos ya no dejan ya no quieren
tener contacto nosotros nos vamos
alejando vienen a comer pero sin
contacto es como que nos van marcando la
distancia y por eso es para ser
reintroducido es como un espectacular la
especie
en 15 años se ha liberado un centenar de
osos hormigueros en esta provincia del
noreste de argentina donde estos
animales habían estado totalmente
ausentes desde la década de 1950 su
adaptación a la vida a la naturaleza se
controla permanentemente mediante
cámaras trampas una victoria para la
biodiversidad resultado de los esfuerzos
de una fundación llamada be waiting'
desde 2007 la fundación aplica el
principio de recibes tracción en el
parque y veras la reintroducción de
especies desaparecidas en su entorno
natural
desde hace algunos años en esta región
la segunda más húmeda del mundo se
vuelven a ver nutrias gigantes y
pecaríes
pero a veces este retorno en la
naturaleza requiere de una larga
preparación
siempre les ponemos la comida en alto
porque son animales que tienen que
aprender a estar en altura es riesgoso
para ellos aprender a comer en el suelo
elena dirige el centro de entrenamiento
de guacamayos o rojos o
antes de aterrizar en y ver a estas
grandes aves pasaron su vida en
zoológicos o en casas particulares
muchos de ellos nunca han tenido la
oportunidad de volar porque han vivido
en el hubble y estás chiquitas con 300
pequeños
y es algo que no han ido desarrollando
no sólo aprenden a volar sino que
adquieren destreza y son capaces de
esquivar objetos e incluso posarse en
lugares irregulares
ejercicios diarios que duran más de un
año en promedio para asegurarse de que
las aves puedan sobrevivir en la
naturaleza para este grupo de 6
guacamayos la liberación está prevista
para la próxima semana este retorno de
la fauna silvestre no puede tener éxito
sin el apoyo de las comunidades locales
juan es oriundo de la región y lleva dos
años trabajando para la fundación
rewarding su objetivo es explicarle a la
población local que la reintroducción y
protección de los animales salvajes
puede beneficiarlos mediante el
desarrollo del turismo
muchos de ellos vivían de la escasa
furtiva y hoy por hoy se dan en cuenta
que un animal vivo
también vale mucho o sea no
necesariamente tiene que matarlo pero
ven que tiene otro beneficio
económicamente
hoy fue a ver cómo estaba amigo
este antiguo cazador furtivo' logró
crear su propio negocio de paseos en
barca tirada por un caballo un medio de
transporte tradicional en la región un
trayecto de dos horas le hace ganar unos
12 dólares por turista
al conseguir el apoyo de las comunidades
locales la ong y waiting se fijó un
nuevo objetivo más ambicioso la
reintroducción de un felino emblemático
extinto en argentina desde hace más de
60 años debido a la caza ya la
deforestación
el año pasado en 2021 se liberaron 7
yaguaretés o recién salió los primeros
días de enero son años de trabajo en
algunos casos
para ese momento
y malú es un animal que viene de
zoológico y por lo tanto tiene mucho
contacto con humanos por lo tanto no se
la va a liberar pero si se lo va a usar
para reproducirlo ya sus crías después
se las podría llegar a liberar en esta
zona inaccesible para los turistas solo
un recinto está ocupado actualmente por
una hembra de 6 años llamada malú fue
trasladada desde uruguay
y regulan las poblaciones de grandes
herbívoros tienen efectos sobre meses o
creadores como por ejemplo zorros y
estos árabes sobre hervido de los
menores y todo esto tiene efectos sobre
la diversidad de la vegetación y la
calidad del suelo en unos meses un
jaguar macho será atraído para aparearse
con malú con la reproducción de ese
súper depredador el equilibrio de un
ecosistema está asegurado cuando tenga
sus crías ma luz será trasladada con
ellas a un recinto más grande para
enseñarles a cazar gracias a todos estos
esfuerzos el parque iberá es hoy el
mayor reservorio de biodiversidad de
argentina